what's the deal with this okay so the
company is called Ocean Gate okay and
it's ran by this genius who built this
submarine and it's piloted with a
Logitech Gamepad controller okay now
first of all
this thing looks like you're freshly
circumcised painting yep so this guy
started this company he engineered this
he engineered this um the intention is
he charges people to take them down to
see the Titanic yes now a key aspect of
it is the capacity is five people for 96
hours but I think they got that second
part wrong why I think it's probably
like five people for 15 minutes yeah
yeah yeah
that's not cool um so yeah uh they so
this guy he created this submarine he
charges 250 000 a seat to go 250k
perceive an experimental submersible
vessel that has not been approved or
certified by any regulatory body and
could result keyword there not approved
by any regulatory body but wait wait
wait but but I mean with the ocean isn't
that like normal
sure but you're saying like safety wise
if you were to get on it you'd be like I
want this to be like certified by
somebody yes okay yeah this is the uh
waiver that he's reading out loud and
could result in physical injury
disability emotional trauma or death
where do I sign that's a customer
no no this is just a reporter oh he's
just being cheeky yeah yeah he went on
he did it oh actually yeah no he did do
it yeah like six months ago or something
and survived well they only I think they
only made it down a certain amount
before that they had something wrong and
they had to go oh my god really yeah
oh my God my theory is that they went
down and something was a little uh
but the guy having this billionaire in
the you know he wanted to impress him he
goes it's fine yeah and they just he
just went a little too far
goodbye so but have people seen the
wreckage the Titanic wreckage on this
thing no so let's get into that but I
just want you to hear okay sure
okay
inside
imagine just being stuck like that
I think the I think the closest we've
gotten to this you know like when you're
crawling around in those Sky tubes at
Chuck E cheese yeah and you look out the
porthole and you just see your mom
eating a pizza ignoring you and you're
like
how do I get out like that's the closest
we've been
and you're screaming at her but like
from the outside it's just yeah
she's just not even looking she's just
down there eating a pizza eating a pizza
the sub has about as much room as a
minivan so this is not your
grandfather's submersible we only have
one button
duh
listen to this I only have one button
that's it it should be like an elevator
you know it shouldn't take a lot of
skill the Titan is the only five points
do you think that button does just
nothing yeah we have one button
yeah
what does that do it just uh well it's
just like a cool design thing I don't
know our partner came up with that he
thinks it looks cool that's the
submarine button yeah
what is what is that this is a button in
a submarine
genius idea yeah makes customer feel
very comfortable you press that when you
see the Titanic yeah it turns green we
got it
2.4 miles below the sea 2.4 miles
see this is what's not fair about this
so far yeah what's not fair about this
is I think everything every stop in this
is just absurdity yeah
like it's just numbers and sentences
that are just funny yeah they're like
I'm sorry they did what they went three
miles below the ocean like is it not
Pitch Black yeah how would you even see
the wreckage at all dude it's like what
in what that's what the button's for
yeah
that's the one light
it's just a headlight yeah it goes two
inches yeah
they're like oh [__]
huh we should have got a bigger light
yeah well okay just listen did you hear
no well how they communicate with with
it no the only way they can communicate
with the people inside is if they are
directly above it and they can send a
text message
to and from other than that if you get
out of range they cannot communicate
with the submarine there's no
communication SMS just doesn't feel like
a smart
yeah what no voice thing nope no because
nothing works underwater
but I mean like there are submarines
like the military yeah brains that work
they don't have that technology I guess
I mean this is not your grandfather's
submersible
yeah your grandfather's submersible is
actually commissioned by the military
it's much more expensive yeah this is um
this is uh this is your son's
submersible all right listen to this
next line it's also the only one with a
toilet sort of can you imagine taking a
[__] oh my God just in the middle of the
six people or just lying on top
laughs
you wouldn't mind would you
only just [__] drop Trow
just [__] I should not have had I had
two McGriddles for breakfast why did I
drink coffee before
blowing it anxieties just [__]
obviously that's what happened someone's
down there they farted too hard yeah
gas changed the oxygen pressure yeah and
they all just blow yeah
oh
well here and yet I could I could help
noticing how many pieces pieces of this
sub seemed improvised we can use these
off-the-shelf components I got these
from uh camper world
Camera World Camper World camper world
yeah
we run the whole thing with this game
controller
now oh my God now
you know
if you know like
I know he got some Gen X people with
this because if you're a millennial you
know for a [__] fact when you're
handed the Mad Catz control yeah yeah
that thing is bunk yep 100 bad yeah
you're so right
you never wanted that one any Millennial
would have looked right at that and gone
no I think so man so true oh you're
gonna give me the one with the Dead uh x
button all right man okay that [__] was
always garbage
and so the fact that it's a Logitech
he he's like we control this whole thing
I'd have been gone yeah yeah well like
why didn't you just use an Xbox one yeah
or a PlayStation controller that's
what's scary about it what you know I
guess because it has to be plugged into
a PC but a modern Xbox controller can be
plugged
there you go see
that would have been way better
Bluetooth too yeah yeah yeah
oh [__] I didn't I did not expect this
turns out bluetooth doesn't work you
have a USBC yikes
you didn't bring it
oh I didn't bring it either that's
probably what happened
foreign
charge it up and then they're like
looking for the ports like oh we had to
close everything off
[__]
oh [__] I forgot to get the port from
camper world
how dude how horrifying would that be
like they're going to the bottom and
this dude's like
everything okay there yeah yeah
and this is just blinking red at the top
like oh God
[__] I forgot to charge it and they're
just
okay it's okay though let me just press
the submarine button
faster oh
[Music]
and pulled this blackberry and send a
text to the crew
that dude so like in retrospect this all
obviously looks very sketchy yeah
and but yet people like like multiple
people paid 250k yeah so to their credit
this guy has been successful before how
many times so there is one guy I just
read uh very successful he's done it 35
times he's gone down and back on this
machine on this machine it looks like uh
let me see if I can find that article
again one guy that's and he's missing
he's he's among the five that are
missing he's like why has he done it so
many times that's a lot of money
I think he likes doing it I don't know
35 divided by four
I feel like you're not attempting fate
at that point I'm bro right if you've
done that 35 times that's eight million
dude yeah well I mean you know you don't
care but I think what's you're saying
10th and fate dude
you gotta feel like you're above fate at
that point yeah yeah I've gone down to
this piece of [__] 35 times I'm good
yeah